um
while I'm out is it season 20 yeah we're
coming up on 20 right now it's crazy
because I do feel like when we think of
like the most successful TV shows ever I
think that like wild 'n out has
surpassed so many of the shows that we
look back on and be like this like I I
think sometimes it's almost like when
LeBron's playing we don't realize we're
watching LeBron yeah yeah and I feel
like one day when wild now it's over
they're going to appreciate it we're
gonna be like damn wowing out was on for
x amount of years and was heat and there
was all these moments with all these
[__] legendary artists yeah just so
many just memorable and the fact that it
was dope about it because you bring up a
good point of like what the definition
of what a TV show is we know because
that's our generation the kids today
don't even understand it to be a TV show
they understand it's like a Tick Tock
YouTube viral sensation kids kids used
to come up to me like oh man I love your
show uh you make it's my favorite show
now kids come up to me like man I love
your videos yeah I love I love you know
like they I love the content like they
literally really say that so it's like
nobody watches the big [__] on the wall
anymore it's like it's in their hands on
the iPads and we're probably more
successful online than we've ever been
than we were on television well the
show's like very great for today's like
environment yeah yeah Eclipse yep them
small we know how to compartmentalize
and break up those clips for you know
all day long and so one of the most I
think we're probably the the uh the
biggest uh digital imprint in uh the
whole entire Paramount Network that
includes Comedy Central that includes
yes and we have more followers on
YouTube more followers on Tick Tock uh
than anything else in in the Paramount
ecosystem so maybe The Daily Show might
be like close on one of those can you
give me um some insight on like the
beginning of wild and out like the break
like like this is your baby this is your
your you know your idea like yeah man I
was just really trying to [__] give
my friends jobs like I did like people
didn't know who Kevin Hart and afion
Crockett d Ray Davis you made a lot of
these guys man they didn't know and I
don't mean
yeah yeah absolutely
um and because actually they were all my
my colleagues and counterparts they were
they were because I came up you were
doing a little stand up at a certain
point in time because you started in San
Diego doing stand-ups yeah yeah I
started doing stand I mean I started
yeah I started in that I started in
music obviously when I was even younger
but stand up is what put me on the mat
got me my first deal at uh Jamie Foxx's
uh Lollapalooza uh in Atlanta and then
from there by the way prayers with Jamie
Foxx yeah always I I'm believing in a
hundred percent complete healing that's
my brother right there we've been
praying strong for I might need security
one of the best specials ever yeah and
first of all he's the most talented man
on the planet 100 yeah I say it's either
him or Chris Brown those are the one and
two those are the two those are the one
and two and only videos because Chris
hasn't been able to spread his wings the
way fox has in the end well I look at
Chris as like Chris is really good at
basketball yeah and he can paint a mural
yeah yeah all these
and both of them like the nicest human
beings in the world so it's like it's
it's you want to go to either party at
either one of those dudes house so for a
while now you kind of come from the
stand-up background these are your
friends these are guys who you consider
your peers and for you it was like what
there's not an outlet well I was doing
movies and music and stuff at the time
so yeah love don't cost a thing was
already on you were popping yeah and
those cats was looking at me like yo man
spread the love so I was like all right
I'm gonna go to MTV because I was I was
hosting TRL doing all that stuff so I
went to them and they didn't understand
it at first they was like do you want to
do what right and I was like nah we got
this comedy club and we do this this
thing is like they didn't really
understand it so I was like all right
[__] it I'll rent The Comedy Club on
myself got some cameras together uh
called everybody to the club and we shot
that [__] and therefore I own the IP
since the day one so you bankrolled the
demo yeah shot the demo yourself that
and then shopped it around and then so
then now I had now I had all the equity
and and the negotiating Powers because
how so for people who don't know I think
a lot of people are a little bit more
familiar with like record deals yeah
yeah so if you're trying to get a TV
show Deal usually a production company
comes in with the money to pay for the
pilot and that's their excuse to take
ownership exactly but if you handle that
yourself
I already got this handled yeah you want
it or not yeah and then that everything
from the the Wild and out logo to all of
us it was all owned by me
was it a scary situation where they
tried getting you up out of here and it
felt like they took you off TV it was
like it was they try to cancel me like
at least once a year well I mean no I
know but there was there was the time I
think uh it was a couple years ago and
you had the interview I forget I don't
want to get into it yeah but that's I
mean that was a learning moment that you
went through with everybody in 100 you
know what I mean but that's the thing
like moments like that uh either show
your toughness and show how quickly you
could fold so you know uh I think Martin
Luther King said it best it was like the
test of the true test of a man's
character isn't in times of comfort but
in times of controversy so that that
just shows you how solid I was to every
Community to where where most people
instantly or they they waver and we're
like I leaned into it and then we began
to to understand and really focus not
only on my business and saw who was
riding with me and who wasn't but then
at the same time uh any wrongdoings that
I I made I corrected as every man should
and I think we need to be more more uh I
mean it's kind of crazy because we don't
give a lot of people that opportunity
anymore yeah and I mean I got another
show that I'm creating uh right now that
I already created that we already shot
that'll be debuting pretty soon but
literally does what deals with that I
mean I coined the Frank Council culture
it's not about cancel culture it's
accountable so don't cancel one another
Council one and they should take your
brother and show them how to shake it up
and how to really get it right and give
them an opportunity none of us are
greater than God and so we should allow
him to be the one to judge yeah I feel
like in a time where like we're so at
least perceived I think we have a lot
more in common than people would like to
talk about yeah they always say there's
more uh there's similarities and
differences small things that people are
far apart on but everything else they
they everyone loves their family
everyone wants to be safe everyone wants
to be Prosper but if you don't agree on
this or this it's like you gotta hate
the other person and I think yeah and
that's I mean a Buddhist mentality is we
are one without uh one without none and
none without one so in that idea of like
we got we need each other to to operate
and if we keep allowing the powers that
be to split us up it really feels like
it is some powers that be [__] bro yeah
like because that's how they control you
they control you divide and conquer
that's right but if we really understand
like again like we got more similarities
and differences in in the [__] that we
bicker about is I mean that's one of the
things that is I say while and I was the
most Progressive show on television
because we can have people from two
different walks of life we can have
someone from the Jewish Community some
from the Muslim Community and they go at
it and hug it out at the end we can have
a homophobic person and a transgender
person go at it and hug it out at the
end because but they talk the most [__]
say the most stereotypical offensive
stuff but when you say it's up all the
gods of family and comedy and humor we
we win so but when you allow that stuff
to be rooted in hate and therefore you
think you better than somebody else
because of your life experience for sure
vice versa that's where [__] goes wrong
yeah I think it's like people will talk
out of like people will make mistakes
and I think that's just human nature
yeah so if someone makes a mistake
that's not from a hateful place exactly
correct talk to them yeah that's why
they put a races on pencils it's like
yeah it's like yo I don't [__] with
Earthlings
so the new show that you you're working
on is called it's called Council culture
yeah you know you're getting the
exclusive here because I actually it
wasn't supposed to talk about that yet
that uh but yeah that's it's something I
I kind of realized man that uh when I
was doing my daytime talk show I was
like this ain't where the bag is you
know what I mean all of that Ellen money
and Oprah money they came and scooped
all of that up yeah it's kind of like
they kind of got the last of that yeah
yeah so I went in there I was like
there's no way this makes sense to make
it takes 16 hours to make one hour and
the bandwidth of doing it every day like
it was trying to do radio like it was
literally draining me so I had to step
away so I was like I want to be able to
do the same thing have the same type of
impact but you know Consolidated into 12
episodes a season or something yeah but
really what what even even on a daily
perspective it's like it has to be able
to be a part of my lifestyle opposed to
me trying to come here and show up for
work like I don't work for nobody so
like when if it feels like I got a job
then I'm I'm out but uh the fact that I
can actually live my life and document
the process and show the process and
actually truly help people and you know
the fact that I go to therapy a few
times a week how can I bring that to the
table the fact that you know I have
great relationships with the mothers and
my children and knowing how fascinated
and intrigued people are by my life how
can I offer that in a way to not only I
can be open and honest and control my
own narrative but then at the same time
you know monetize it